las soluciones buffer también conocidas
como soluciones amortiguadoras o tampón
pueden resistir los cambios de ph
pensemos en una solución de un ácido
débil y su base conjugada aquí tenemos
un ácido general chea y su base
conjugada es a menos una solución buffer
necesita tener una buena cantidad de los
dos y eso es lo que trato de representar
aquí aquí tenemos un vaso y en este caso
tenemos la misma cantidad de h
a menos ya esta solución buffer le vamos
a agregar un ácido fuerte es decir una
fuente de protones voy a dibujar un
protón por acá además aunque pude haber
puesto h 3 o más porque h más y h2o o
forman h 3 o más pero prefería escribir
h más para que sea más fácil entonces si
incrementamos la concentración de iones
h más oggioni sidronio en la
bueno podríamos pensar que el ph
disminuiría drásticamente y seguramente
eso sucedería si no tuviéramos algo más
que pudiera reaccionar con los protones
en solución nosotros tenemos una
solución buffer tenemos la base a menos
y la base puede tomar este protón así h
más y a menos formen h
se forma más ácido débil vamos a ver
empezamos con un poco de ácido dv lo
dibujaré h
y podemos formar más porque h más y a
menos producen h así que formamos más
ácido débil y que me dicen de a menos
bueno en este caso usamos uno de estos
para formar h
así que sólo nos quedan dos entonces
disminuye la concentración de a menos
pero lo que hicimos fue quitar protones
de la solución y así es como una
solución buffer puede resistirse
a un cambio de ph en este caso si
agregamos ácido pero qué pasará si
agregamos una base
bueno aquí tenemos nuevamente nuestra
solución buffer y esta vez vamos a
agregar una base fuerte vamos a
disminuir la concentración de iones
hidróxido en la solución y si
disminuimos la concentración de iones
hidróxido podríamos pensar que eso
aumenta el ph drásticamente pero
observen que tenemos un ácido que puede
reaccionar con la base aquí tenemos un
ácido débil así que el ión hidróxido
puede tomar un protón del h
aquí tenemos h más entonces o h menos y
h más claro formen h2o formamos agua
y así perdemos un poco del ácido débil
en este caso
empezamos con 3 y ahora sólo tenemos 2 y
como el o h - le quitó un protón a este
h nos queda a menos aumentamos la
concentración de a menos en la solución
vamos a dibujarla entonces nuevamente
amortigua mos el cambio drástico de ph
ya que los iones hidróxido que agregamos
en este caso reaccionaron con el ácido
que estaba presente y con eso pudimos
quitar algunos iones hidróxido de la
solución esta es la idea de una solución
buffer o amortiguador veamos si podemos
obtener alguna ecuación que nos ayude a
realizar los cálculos vamos a ver
nosotros tenemos una solución buffer con
una buena cantidad de h
ya menos presentes así que esta reacción
se encuentra en equilibrio
y la ecuación de equilibrio es igual a
la concentración de los reactivos entre
la de los productos sin tomar en cuenta
el agua entonces vamos a sacar el menos
logaritmo de ambos lados de esta
ecuación empecemos con acá tenemos menos
logaritmo tk a es igual a menos el
logaritmo de todo esto entonces menos
logaritmo de voy a escribirlo un poco
diferente pondré la concentración de
iones sidronio al principio y después
tenemos la concentración de a menos
entre la concentración de h
lo escribí así porque es un poco más
fácil aplicar las propiedades de los
logaritmos por ejemplo si tenemos el
logaritmo de a por b esto es igual al
logaritmo de a más el logaritmo de b y
aquí tenemos un menos logaritmo así que
el menos logaritmo de
es igual a el menos logaritmo de a más
del logaritmo de b que nos queda como
menos el logaritmo pp ahora en este caso
la concentración de h 3 o más sería a y
esta parte sería de entonces
apliquemos esta propiedad de los
logaritmos del lado izquierdo tenemos
menos logaritmo de k
y del lado derecho nos queda menos
logaritmo de a es decir menos logaritmo
de la concentración de h tres o más
menos el logaritmo de b&b corresponde a
esta parte así que tenemos menos
logaritmo de a menos entre h
ok ahora sabemos que el menos logaritmo
de caja es igual a peka peka
y de este lado tenemos el menos
logaritmo de la concentración de iones y
drones que es igual al ph el menos
logaritmo de la concentración de h 3 o
más es igual al ph y después tenemos
menos el logaritmo de la concentración
de a menos entre la concentración de h
y podemos reescribir esto para la
ecuación final ph es igual al pk a más
el logaritmo de a menos entre la
concentración de h
a esta ecuación se le conoce como la
ecuación de henderson hazel back y la
ecuación de henderson hazel back es muy
útil para los cálculos con soluciones
amortiguadoras veremos algunos ejemplos
en el siguiente vídeo